once again as a public service to this
year's Comic Con attendees here are some
panels this weekend if you're interested
that have very very short lines you'll
get in you'll get out on Sunday there's
a game of Thrones Starbucks cup shares
its next project yeah yeah yeah then
there's a Chernobyl and all Amish
production of the HBO hit Chernobyl
there's yeah right
there's learn to make sausages with Vin
Diesel stunt double Clegg mantle yeah
there's the folding tables from
comic-con 1982 still folding after all
these years
hey check this one out margot robbie
ignores you in a hotel elevator I can't
believe nobody's going it out they're
going to that yeah hey check this out
George Lucas's passion project his
unaired pert plus commercials yeah right
and finally Andy Richter will silently
scowl at you for 45 minutes
that's just a little taste well chase
yeah I'm scared you have to chant my
name but the minute I try and get him to
do my bidding they all chickened out